.
BRIAN: NOT TRUE.
THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE.
AND THIS MESS IS SPIRALING OUT
OF CONTROL AS OFFICIALS ARE
WARNING OF FENTANYL THAT LOOKS
LIKE CANDY WITH HALLOWEEN JUST
AROUND THE CORNER.
AND TEXAS CAN'T HANDLE THE
STREAM OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
ENTERING OUR COUNTRY.
HERE TO DISCUSS THE UNSECURE
BORDER, DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
FROM A BORDER TOWN IN TEXAS, A
LONE VOICE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE AS THAT I CAN TELL.
CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR, A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED BY THE
MAYOR THURSDAY.
HE CAN'T HANDLE 13,000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> I FEEL THE FRUSTRATION THAT
HE FEELS.
I AM A BORDER COMMUNITY AND THE
BORDER PATROL AND MEN AND WOMEN
OF HOMELAND HAVE FELT THIS
FRUSTRATION.
WE HAVE BEEN FEELING THIS FOR
OVER 10 YEARS.
LISTEN TO THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
IN -- IN GREEN AND BLUE.
OTHERWISE IT WILL GO TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., CHICAGO, AND
OTHER PLACES.
BRIAN: THE BUSING OF MIGRANTS TO
BLUE STATES HAS FINALLY GOTTEN
ATTENTION BECAUSE THIS BORDER IS
BEING IGNORED.
HOW BAD IS THIS COMPARED TO
ANYTHING YOU HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
>> LAST YEAR WE HAD 1.7 MILLION
WHO GOT TO THE BORDER.
THIS YEAR ONCE WE GET THE FINAL
NUMBERS IT WILL BE 2.3.
YOU ADD THE GET AWAYS.
AND YOU ARE TALKING SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 4 TO 5 MILLION
INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN NUMBERS LIKE
THIS.
I'M HERE TWO FEET AWAY FROM THE
RIVER.
EVERY PART OF THE BORDER IS
DIFFERENT.
THE CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS, THEY
CONTROL RIGHT ACROSS THE RIVER
WHERE I'M AT.
THEY CONTROL WHERE THE PEOPLE
ARE SENT.
AND WHAT THEY DO IS PROBABLY
MAKING MORE MONEY PASSING PEOPLE
THAN PASSING DRUGS.
AND THEY ARE LOOK AT SMUGGLING.
NOW THEY ARE CHANGING IT TO
TRAFFICKING.
WHEN THEY DO TRAFFIC PEOPLE,
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR THEIR OWN
TO THE -- WHERE THEY ARE OWNED
BY THE DRUG CARTELS FOR YEARS TO
COME.
BRIAN: YOU TOLD BILL MELUGIN
THAT MAJORKAS TOLD YOU THE LEFT
WING IMMIGRANT GROUPS HAVE
GOTTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
THE LEFT WING GROUPS HAVE GOT TO
THE PRESIDENT WHERE HE DOESN'T
WANT TO ACT TO STOP THIS.
CORRECT?
>> ACTUALLY WHAT I TOLD HIM WAS
THAT IN MY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS THERE THAT
HAVE IMMIGRATION BACKGROUND
ACTIVISTS.
THEY RUN IMMIGRATION CENTERS.
THEIR POLICIES ARE DRIVING
HOMELAND SECURITY POLICY.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS, THEY ARE
LISTENING TO THE IMMIGRATION
ACTIVISTS.
WHO IS LISTENING TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN GREEN AND BLUE, WHO IS
LISTENING TO THE BORDER
COMMUNITIES.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO ME.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE SANCTUARY
CITY ALONG THE BORDER.
FLOILS MAYOR, COUNTY JUDGE,
POLICE CHIEF OR SHERIFF.
NONE OF THEM ARE SAYING OPEN UP
THE BORDER AND LET EVERYBODY IN.
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
TO OUR BORDER COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY THE LANDOWNERS.
BRIAN: ALL THEY SEE IS A WELCOME
WAGON IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY SAY IF YOU COME YOU CAN
STAY.
IT'S THE WRONG MESSAGE CAUSING
PEOPLE TO COME HERE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS NO
PART OF YOU.
THEY PRIMARIED YOU TWICE AND
WHEN THEY COME TO THE BORDER
THEY DON'T LOOK YOU UP.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO YOUR PARTY?
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS A BIG
TENT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO TOLD ME QUIETLY, HENRY, I AM
GRATEFUL FOR WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
BUT THEY WON'T SPEAK UP.
BUT IF YOU DON'T LIVE AT THE
BORDER, A GOOD NUMBER OF THEM
HAVE TOLD ME, THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU ARE DOING AT THE BORDER.
BRIAN: BECAUSE YOU SHOW GUTS.
BY THEM QUIETLY TELLING YOU
THAT, THEY ARE NOT.
I THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO ON A
DAILY BASIS.
I KNOW YOU COULD SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM IF THEY WOULD JUST
LISTEN TO YOU.
I'M GLAD YOU WON YOUR PRIMARY.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN TO THE
BORDER AND THANK Y